este vídeo le enseñará cómo manejar y
tratar el nivel alto de azúcar en sangre
sírvase ver todo el vídeo antes de
realizar el tratamiento del nivel alto
de azúcar en sangre
después de ingerir alimentos que
contengan carbohidratos su cuerpo los
descompone en un azúcar denominado
glucosa
su cuerpo produce una hormona denominada
insulina que le ayuda a usar o almacenar
el azúcar en sangre
cuando tiene diabetes su cuerpo no
produce suficiente insulina o no puede
usar la insulina de forma adecuada
esto puede producir que tenga demasiada
azúcar en sangre una condición
denominada hiperglucemia
la hiperglucemia puede producirse cuando
usted no toma suficiente insulina un
medicamento para la diabetes toma
medicamentos que aumentan el nivel de
azúcar en sangre
come más alimentos o carbohidratos de
los que debería
no realiza suficiente actividad física o
ejercicios
está enfermo lesionado o tuvo una
cirugía
tiene estrés emocional como problemas
familiares o laborales
o tiene cambios en los niveles
hormonales como durante los periodos de
menstruación
si tiene hiperglucemia o su nivel de
azúcar en sangre es muy alto es posible
que tenga mucha sed
y que tenga que orinar demasiado
también puede sentirse muy cansado
y notar una visión borrosa
si no se trata la hiperglucemia su nivel
de azúcar en sangre puede aumentar a un
nivel peligrosamente alto que requiera
la atención de emergencia inmediata el
primer paso para comprender cómo tratar
el nivel alto de azúcar en sangre es
conocer su rango objetivo de nivel de
azúcar en sangre normal
si siente o nota síntomas de
hiperglucemia asegúrese de revisar su
nivel de azúcar en sangre inmediatamente
si su nivel de azúcar en sangre está por
encima del rango objetivo
asegúrese de beber suficiente agua u
otro líquido sin azúcar para mantenerse
hidratado
tomar la insulina o medicamento para la
diabetes según la indicación de su
proveedor de atención médica
no tome medicamentos adicionales sin
consultar primero con su proveedor de
atención médica
revise su nivel de azúcar en sangre cada
4 horas
siga con su plan de alimentación normal
y si puede aumentar la actividad física
o el ejercicio
no realiza actividad física si su nivel
de azúcar está por encima de 240
realizar actividad física puede elevar
aún más su nivel de azúcar en sangre
comuníquese con su proveedor de atención
médica si su nivel de azúcar en sangre
permanece por encima del rango objetivo
o si nota los siguientes síntomas que
requieren tratamiento inmediato le falta
el aliento el aliento huele a frutas o
siente la boca muy seca
puede ayudar a prevenir la hiperglucemia
de la siguiente manera revisar
frecuentemente su nivel de azúcar en
sangre seguir un plan de alimentación
normal tomar el medicamento para la
diabetes que le recetó su médico
y controlar el estrés
y realizar actividad física regularmente